hi i'm sohali khan and i want to send a  huge congratulations to indian teacher  ranjeet vasily who is a finalist for the  global teacher prize 2020. it's an  incredible achievement to have been  chosen from over 12  000 nominations and applications from  across the world and ranjit you've  really taught girls and their families  the importance of staying in school  there are now no teenage marriages in  your village and 100  attendance in school which is fantastic  the global teacher prize which partners  with unesco  shines a light on inspiring teachers  like you in every corner of the planet  the world is facing some of its greatest  challenges today but backing teachers  will help light the way  for a better future